Let's look into whether bootstrapping
your business is the right
option for you.
Before we get started,
what is bootstrapping?
Bootstrapping is the act
of financing your business
using your own personal resources.
You'll use what you currently have
available to start building and
growing your company.
There are a few things to be aware of
before considering bootstrapping for
your business.
First let's look at
some of the benefits.
We'll focus on three major benefits
of bootstrapping, freedom,
profits and commitment.
First, freedom.
Financing your business yourself
provides you a level of freedom not
available to you once
investors become involved.
Sometimes you need to be flexible and
make tough choices.
Being on your own, you don't need
to rationalize with investors.
This will allow you to make your own
decisions about what is best for
the company.
That said,
you can't build a business in a vacuum.
Successful bootstrappers leverage their
personal and professional networks and
grow their businesses organically.
Remember to focus on your customer base,
social presence, and
the momentum you generate through
your business's popularity.
Next, profits.
Without investors, the profits your
business generates come straight to you.
When bootstrapping, you retain equity in
your company and hold shares that would
normally go to investors if they
had put money into your startup.
And finally, commitment.
There's nothing that gets you motivated
to figure out your business quite like
financing it yourself.
Bootstrapping can give you the extra
incentive needed to work the long hours
necessary to become successful.
This experience can definitely help you
become a more resourceful entrepreneur.
While there are benefits
to bootstrapping,
it's important to understand some
ways it might not be so great.
Let's focus on three major downsides of
bootstrapping, expenses, connections,
and credibility.
First, expenses.
Launching your startup
can take a lot of money.
Trying to supply this on your own
can become detrimental to your
personal expenses.
This could end up affecting
decisions you make.
If you're low on money,
you might end up making changes that
aren't in the best interest of your
company to chase early profits.
This can really stunt
your long term growth.
Next, connections.
A lot of investors have been
in business for many years and
have access to tons of resources.
Working on your own you have less
of these resources available for
your business.
You also lose any access to the people
within the investors network who could
advise you as you build your company.
When bootstrapping,
you're missing out on some of
these opportunities for growth.
And finally,
being backed by the right investor gives
immediate credibility to your business.
When bootstrapping you might not
be able to get this otherwise.
Without investor support,
it could make it more difficult to
get investment in later seed rounds.
So, take some time to
consider the benefits and
downsides of Bootstrapping your startup.
When you're ready, decide if you
think this would be a good option for
your business.